OK, I want to now do a little bit of a deep
dove into a recent poll.
This is an utterly devastating poll for Donald
Trump with the normal caveats.
It's May.
Things can change very quickly between now
and November.
Look at how quickly they changed for Joe Biden.
Within 72 hours after the South Carolina primary.
Now there is a Fox News poll that says Trump
is losing 48 to 40 to Joe Biden right now.
I know some of you will say, David, a Fox
News poll.
What the hell are you doing?
That's crazy.
Fox News.
Why do we care?
Fox News polling is its own enterprise.
They are well ranked as far as polling goes.
And they were pretty accurate back in 2016
by.
Thirty eight ranks.
Two different Fox News polling partnerships
as an either A minus or a slash B. So Fox
News polling is actually pretty reliable.
It's very different than what you hear on
their airwaves.
On the question of Trump versus Biden nationally,
Joe Biden has an eight point lead, 48 to 40.
Trump is winning among men and Trump is winning
among whites.
Losing a ton of other important splits.
So Trump is losing women to Joe Biden.
Trump is losing black and Hispanic voters.
Trump is losing all nonwhite voters.
Trump is losing people under 45.
Trump is losing people over 45.
Trump is losing people earning under $50000
a year and people earning more than $50000
a year.
But there's something really interesting when
you look at some of the other splits, according
to this poll.
Four percent of Democrats plan to vote for
Trump and 8 percent of Republicans plan to
vote for Biden.
Understand that if 2016 essentially holds
with the one change of 4 percent of Democrats,
abandon the Democratic Party and vote Trump,
8 percent of Republicans abandon Trump and
vote for Joe Biden.
That's all you need to flip a bunch of states.
I'll give you just one example.
We're gonna use Hillary and Trump 2016 numbers
to think about this.
So in Wisconsin in 2016, Hillary Clinton lost
by just under 23000 votes.
Each candidate got about 1.4 million votes.
Trump just over 1.4 million.
Clinton just under 1.3 million.
So this is very simple math.
You take 4 percent of Hillary's votes from
2016 and assign them to Trump.
You take 8 percent of Trump's votes.
And imagine that they went to Hillary or,
you know, potentially they would go to Joe
Biden.
That alone would have given Hillary Clinton
a ninety one 1000 vote victory in Wisconsin
instead of a loss.
So that is just one state.
It is just one example.
But understand this idea that we basically
maintain 2016.
If four percent of Democrats switch and eight
percent of Republicans switch.
Trump loses.
Now I want to make it again.
I know people said, David, would you know
these disclaimers maybe aren't necessary.
They are necessary.
Right now we have a long way to go.
This is a snapshot of right now.
If the perception of the economy improves
by November.
If the perception of how things are going
with corona virus improves by November, we
may very, very quickly see this.
These numbers reverse dramatically.
We must all vote.
We must all get out the vote, etc..
Lastly, just one other thing on issues.
Trump is always in these polls, strongest
on the economy.
Trump is still stronger than Biden on the
economy.
In this latest Fox News poll.
But it's by a far narrower margin than we've
seen throughout Trump's presidency.
Lastly on China, Trump in great part ran not
just on I'll fix the economy, even though
the economy was doing quite well when Trump
was running.
Trump ran on.
I know how to deal with China.
I know how to deal with trade right now.
Joe Biden is polling as more trustworthy on
China.
That is one of Trump's primary issues.
Alongside this amorphous, all encompassing
economic issues that he tends to do well on,
those issue based numbers are very, very important.
Let me know what you think.
Make sure you are subscribed to the Daily
David Pakman Show audio podcast.
Get it on i-Tunes stitcher or any podcast
app that you prefer.
We'll be back after this with some interesting
videos to play
for you.
It's much.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman Dadgum.